over there
I got a boy in anywhere
no sir absolutely man yeah you already
know come on I'd be up there yeah you
know the money I'm trying to pay I'm not
rooting against the Heat I'm just root
for my Celtics man said I'm not rooting
against the Heat I'm just rooting for
the Celtics but the Celtics and the heat
are playing yup I bet these people on
here like man they defensive playbook
must be easy because it's so crazy what
position would you play if you were in
the NBA I'll be like Charles Barkley
I'll be a stretch three four I want to
be a stretch four stretch four I played
a one or the two my game kind of like
Russell Westbrook kind of like a lot of
energy getting a rebounds the triple
doubles all of that you get to play in
the NBA game you get 30 minutes of burn
how many points do you think you can
score ten if I get a chance to get in
the NBA game shots going on and they
give me 30 minutes I'm gonna be the
worst teammate you ever had I'm shooting
every time go go dunk or something go
grab your room he want me to go uh on
the court Social Security and kick me
out before the game
[Music]
[Applause]
that's good
yay
[Applause]
that's a charge oh boy good ass pictures
jumped over them you need to get a raise
it's a different a different lens I'll
get one shot
stand machine
second quarter heat up 32-22 10 point
game
y'all see where we at with it feet on
the hardwood it's a long game Christian
wants to do another tank
you ain't get enough money you gotta get
more me in there
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
come to Clemson and give us 40.
yeah it might have might not have missed
the shot
thank you
I was about to start the comeback that's
about to spark the comeback no it's not
[Applause]
[Music]
I can't wait till they look over here
why
let's go to get in the game you go about
30. I'm actually close together you guys
live here I I knew he was gonna go over
80. but he will get 80. we might as well
go on 40. the world is going this might
get in there and after him was used
they might be
oh
[Applause]
hey man congratulations to the hell of a
game man that was awesome I tried to get
in real quickly when they was up about
30 because it wouldn't let me in though
man three over and you can see we
beatboxing heat up 3-0 still undefeated
when I'm in the building he was going
for the heat they got his white shirt on
I ain't got much to say the shoes don't
matter it wasn't all night 26 Point win
all them boys ball coach should have put
me in at the end of the game because it
was that easy